the white house turning a blind eye to
the mess they created at the border as
thousands of immigrants pour across
daily press secretary karine jean-pierre
made this outrageously false claim
somebody unvaccinated comes over
on a plane you say that's not okay
somebody walks into texas or arizona
unvaccinated they're allowed to stay
why but that's not how it works like we
actually know we know that that's not
what you guys want to happen but that is
what has happened but that's not it's
not like somebody walks over and
that's not that's not how exactly what's
happening
thousands of people are walking in a day
some of them
turn themselves over some of them are
caught tens of thousands a week are not
that is what is happening
here's national border patrol council
president brandon judd
she does know it and i watch these these
people walk across the border every
single day we see it
it's disgusting what we're seeing and
she knows exactly what's happening but
she's deflecting she's lying she knows
that the mainstream media isn't going to
cover this issue
you know what's interesting about all
this dana is you have to wonder what the
journalists in the room who know whether
they watch fox or whether they watch any
uh uh network they know that there are
people who are crossing the borders i
mean this is their business i mean what
are they thinking can they believe
anything she says this is well it's
interesting i think partly they're
thinking
if i ask her about immigration i won't
get on air tonight because my company my
media company is not covering it i'm not
going to get on air my story's not going
to be on the front page i need to ask
things like about mega republicans and
trump so that i can get on air now here
at fox you know that bill mollusion is
and griff jenkins casey stegall matt
finn they've been doing an amazing work
down at the border i'll ask them
do you see any of the reporters down
there today nope you know when they did
they finally saw reporters or at least
cover the issue when governor greg
abbott decided to send some migrants to
new york and washington dc and then they
were forced to i have to say that from
her perspective the press secretary
knowing that these ques she should have
known that these questions were going to
come okay because it's pretty obvious
that you've got a problem at the border
with everybody coming across and you've
got novak djokovic and the u.s open
about to start and he can't come if you
don't know that that is going to be a
story from friday to monday you need
better support staff and what i would
have gone to ron clayne and said hey
guys we got a problem here and by monday
when i brief i need a better answer and
if i don't have a better answer i'm
going to tell everybody in the press
room that i asked for a better answer
and didn't get one
and that's what forces a policy that can
force a policy change in a discussion at
the white house you know the fact that
um harold she can't answer why a
professional world world-class a tennis
player
can't come into the country unvaccinated
when
almost 2 million at this point have come
across the southern border it's not just
a question of whether or not she's
prepared for it but she can't even
answer it um there's no follow-up
there's nothing i mean is the white
house at this point so convinced that
they can get away with this that they
can get away with anything
it's a lot of questions but i think that
what is clear to me is that this policy
is not working um we don't have a policy
that is protecting our national
sovereignty that's protecting the
integrity of our borders
uh or the stability in this hemisphere
the the thing with djokovic i'll let
that let that rest but to your point
dana she should have known that question
was going to come right i think your
your advice which i think is emerging of
what you and the judge are saying you
got to get a better answer uh we all see
it with our own eyes just so everyone
understands when someone a migrant
crosses the border
and they ask for asylum they get
processed they ask for asylum and
they're given a date what governor
abbott has done is sent a bunch of
migrants here in new york city with
assuming presumably they have dates then
presumably none of them are going to
show up for those dates i don't know if
the new york is planning on sending all
these people back when their dates if
they actually have a record of that but
this is a problem whether you're a
democrat or republican and it has
existed under democrat and republican
presidents but it has worsened over the
last two years without question and you
don't in a way i judge that the metric i
use is just a number of people who've
come across the border it's been
exacerbated by by the pandemic and i
think the question is a legitimate one
about djokovic he should just get
vaccinated but the question but the
press secretary has to be prepared for
that question the policy is not working
and if we don't send more asylum judges
there if we don't keep people in mexico
or wherever other country they're coming
from while they're waiting for their
solemn hearing this problem is only
going to worsen and it will be on all of
our hands
do you think any of these people are
worried about their asylum hearing do
you think they even know when they are
listen if
what happens in dalton georgia is by the
time they make it on that bus where
they're going there's a new green card
with a different name a different social
security number or whatever or whatever
identification number uh
that they that they register for it's a
fake alias there's an entire
infrastructure for it i saw it my entire
life my the kids i went to school with
their last name would change from when
we go from elementary school to middle
school because their parents changed
their identity because the irs was hot
on their trail that's just the truth of
it now i'm not demonizing those people
i'm not saying they're rotten people i'm
not saying anything negative about them
as human beings but as crime as country
goes they're committing fraud and
they're doing on top of of crossing the
border illegally why she gave that
answer is super simple
the answer is they can control who comes
in on a plane they can't control the
border the border is wide open that's
the truth but for her to admit that
would be to call mayorkas and everybody
above him a liar and she can't do that
from the podium
you know interesting jimmy some of the
comments were they could have very on
twitter mocking uh karine jean-pierre
was they could at very least have found
someone better at lying
or if you have to lie uh you have to be
competent no i know because it just
looks so absurd the korean jump here
would get out there and tell you nobody
drinks at mardi gras you're like what do
you mean i got beads all over my neck
what are you talking about it's madness
but what drives me crazy is just the
dereliction of duty there was a woman
who spoke in the a block she wasn't very
passionate but she seemed to oppose
biden's police support
it's kind of low
but stick with me okay
the fentanyl subject that you brought up
earlier it is the leading cause of death
for americans between the ages of 18 and
45. it's not cove but it's not trump's
tax returns okay it's fentanyl and the
fact that this generation is turning a
blind eye towards that fentanyl because
it's not politically expedient to admit
there's a border crisis i just think is
disgraceful it is i agree ahead don't
get fooled by this democrats now trying
to act like they never called for covet
lockdown i went on brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page this is the only way that i know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now